it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gonna keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when it was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do it right
[Music]
back at it again
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby
yeah back from tahiti you got it's very
tall and good looking up in here we got
jeff dye taking over for a mystery
brandon shop taking over
no you look good dude last time some
people say hey this guy he looks
he looks hung over i said i'm going to
be a little lady because it gives me
more time to get the bags under my eyes
under control to get all those ladies
out of my house
get out of here i gotta go record a
podcast dude [ __ ] in sports that's
what this guy's about
[ __ ] sports and coffee you're trying
to sound cool
yeah you know that's what we're talking
about before we started i understand i
see you got a little merch going
oh no this is a that's not mine don't
you have a pitching jersey or something
or what do you mean i don't know it
looks like it on your instagram you have
some merch i don't know
all right neither do i you an iphone i
don't sell anything i sell cds that's
how old school i am
you do this one day i turn into an old
guy you know like it's just like ah it's
cds they're like that's out i was like
it was fine yesterday i've been quoting
your joke you have a great joke which is
uh why does everybody who's in the
crypto have three roommates oh yeah yeah
nobody ever rich talks to me about
crypto or nfts it's always like a
skateboarder like an uber driver yeah my
dumb friend that has like three
roommates he's like you gotta get into
crypto i was like i'm not taking any
financial advice from you dude that's a
hundred percent true everybody i know is
super rich they go like this they go
yeah yeah i play around that's right or
they say this is the best thing a rich
guy can say you wouldn't understand and
i go yeah you're probably right
like they go i'm really rich my finance
guys do it all i go that's a maybe when
i get a bunch of money i'll have finance
guys i asked my brother-in-law who is a
retired at 40 yeah and i said i had some
money i go well so how would i invest he
goes no no he just goes no no don't
worry about it it's just yeah it's too
much and also like i got some friends
too they'll be like yeah just put a
i just got a little bit of money from my
like uh my grandpa's life insurance i'm
thinking about putting into stocks and
stuff i was like oh how much money is it
i'm probably gonna put a few hundred
it's like that's not
what what are you a few hundred in a
stock hundred thousand yeah
it's like at least be in the thousands
if you're gonna invest in something not
hundreds everything is like that though
like if you if you ask a really good
tennis player or a boxer like hey uh
when i transition here i can't dig to
the body they look at you and they go
i mean what are you asking me uh you
it's like hey what's when i do stand up
i've been doing it for 10 minutes when i
do stand up should i i'm not answering
any of your questions do it for 10 years
then come talk to me i can't help you
yeah yeah i can't teach you any tricks
you just got to do it you got gotta do
it yeah yeah the financial stuff it's
like
sorry do you think people get mbas or
become like that this is like a ten
minute conversation now you're expert in
stocks that's why i don't gamble because
like uh i'm two one i'm too cheap to
gamble uh because i'll be like all right
what if i put a thousand dollars down on
the bangles to win this super bowl
against the rams my guy's like you'll
make uh you if they win you'll get about
400 bucks i was like i have to risk a
thousand no can i get 400 bucks and
they're like like yeah that's how it
works go this is terrible terrible
that's not worth the risk and i would
have lost all that money you guys know
that if you heard of camels do you think
you'd do well no i'm terrible at it
i've never been the only thing i've ever
predicted is that johnny manziel was
going to be garbage
and i predicted that uh
like i've been able to predict a few of
the world series winners but they
weren't real gambles you know it was
like oh the yankees are good why do you
think johnny manziel was going to be
garbage i thought he was going to be
amazing because he's undersized and he's
a terrible work ethic and if you're
going to be that small you better work
your ass off you better be like russell
wilson or flutie or yeah like drew brees
um you can't be small and out partying
every night and and acting like a
jackass and
also he's doing that in college yeah he
was yeah like anybody that uh knew him
was always talking about how fun he is
and how he's always drinking and
dressing up like scooby-doo and [ __ ] and
uh but the
the dog was the dog scooby-doo
yeah yeah all right good and then
oh but the thing was like also in
college you'd watch guys just barely
miss him when they're trying to sack him
yeah and just barely like johnny manzo
was barely evading these guys
now those guys don't hold a candle to
like nfl players those of the nfl guys
don't
they're not going to miss yeah they're
not going to miss so i was like they're
going to and they're going to especially
as a quarterback they're going to figure
you out yeah quickly in seven games yeah
they got all your tendencies i gotta say
i've been watching ufc because i became
boys with you guys
gosh there's so many fighters
yeah how do you keep track i mean i
thought that don't just stick to the top
guys oh you stick to the top stuff yeah
or just watch the pre like i watch the
prelims for entertainment but you get to
see the narratives but i think we're
fighting this there's so many guys and
we're opening these cards on the on the
other podcast here well we got 12 packs
with jeff i'm opening all these ufc
cards i don't know any of them
where's patty where's uh connor i don't
know anytime
but think about think about this way
it's not just fighting like what's fun
about watching fighters at the high
level is they have to figure each other
out right so so every each fighter hat
comes with a game plan but they also the
top guys also can improvise and do
incredible things on the fly right in a
split second time but for the most part
they know you have weaknesses their your
team
knows that you might not be as good a
wrestler you might not be as strong in
the clench you may not be you know
whatever it is right yeah and so your
job is to solve the the puzzle in front
of you it's like you have to solve the
fight does that make sense that does
yeah once you watch that then you're
looking at it differently you're like oh
the strategy there like if i watch
boxing and i watch like i'm dying to see
bud crawford fight earl spence earl
spence is so strong he's got such good
understanding of distance and he's just
a beast but bud crawford is just kind of
a genius like he can fight from he can
hit he can do both sides he's just
really hard to figure out and somehow he
figures out your pattern he'll figure
out
what you're doing like chess yes yeah
he's just a better chess player i watch
it like uh you know i i body shame them
first you know i look at their bodies
and i got a terrible body oh what look
at that stupid tattoo and then uh then i
pick based on who looks cooler
and then um
usually i'm wrong
yeah i watch it like a woman would watch
sports i still do that i've been
watching ufc since the beginning and i
still do i body shame i'm terrible oh i
wonder who he's dating you know that i
watch it like a woman like a woman
watches sports if a woman's with you you
have them like who do you think's gonna
win just based on body right well and
that's how i do it but then that's also
why i'd be a terrible gambler you got to
do your homework like allen you know
he's going oh this guy does this and
this guy i don't gamble i don't do any
of that i go when are we eating is this
magical almost this saturday oh that's a
lot of
blood this saturday we have the
best-looking two best-looking guys
fighting paul acosta
and luke rockhold are you remember
what's his name uh dan hooker i thought
that guy was gonna win for sure and then
he's every bone in his skeleton got
broken yeah that was terrible to watch
and you guys are like friends with all
these guys must be even harder for you
some of them i'm friends with luke for
sure but that's paula costa he he's just
a [ __ ] he's jacked he's just he's no
tattoos you never see that
oh yeah a lot never mind cherry blossom
and some birds
magpies
that guy's look at him
because you're hawaiian right
what is this guy's deal paula costa
he's just he's fighting look he is
fighting luke rockhold take a look at
luke i like the name rockhold that's a
strong name luke rock holds a handsome
son good god this guy's gonna win i
think
that's luke rocco couple handsome
straight white and male i know who i'm
rooting for
i'm betting on that sis yeah that's cis
male 1 against that gay brazilian trans
that is weird i have the only group i'm
not allowed to root for him
oh there you go
that must be rare when you're a fighter
guy to have any kind of uh modeling face
yeah
because you get punched in it a lot yeah
yep
he's one that he's by far i'm not real
one i don't really like that image
one of the best ever to do it the other
photo you had was pretty cool but this
one is weird when also he you i do this
pose right like he's much stronger than
me but this is what i do when i have my
shirt off i'm always like in a position
where like my abs you know like
he's got his arms locked so he can pop
the traps you know it's like it looks a
little too intentional there yeah
he also looks great he doesn't even need
to he's got big old muscles that's just
what he looks like yeah i don't i no
matter what i do i don't have any of
that doesn't that seem like a guy that
would
[ __ ] your ex-girlfriend yes he was gonna
seem like a guy he'd go this guy well
your girl your girl will [ __ ] him first
of all your girl will that's what i said
well slide into his dms and then if you
have nothing to say about it because
he'll give you a good beat i'll have
plenty to say about it yeah who's this
chick with him right there i don't know
probably modeling girl she's pretty hot
but jeff you she looks you're funny and
you're taller than her yeah i'll do all
right yeah i'll slide into her dms jesus
dude what's with these muscles
wow that guy make you laugh
that is one of my favorite things brandt
tobler used to always say he's like man
we should be on the i would be on the
bachelor i'd kill it like what makes you
think that these are like the best
looking people in the world ever the
bachelor cast just based on looks you
know they want you to be a garbage
person inside have you have they asked
you to do it yeah a bunch of times i
just don't want to do it yeah and they
um there's no money first of all and
then also they make you look like an
idiot and then also i don't want to
i'll fight over one gal you're a comic
sounds stupid but my buddy branstad we
would do great on there because
long after these guys abs are gone we're
still interesting and fun and funny you
know like like most of those guys are
way hotter but they don't have like a
personality they're not you can't beat a
comic no hanging out having fun laughs
there's no way no way have you ever
heard a regular person's stories that's
true
good god most boring [ __ ] yeah oh yes
the fbi is looking at me yeah yeah i
went to germany once he goes shut up
i went to germany there's all their
stores
oh here comes that germany story again
yeah and i'm nice so i'm like yeah oh
yeah that's germany
i just said but i'm not interested at
all let's take a break jeff listen when
it comes to sleep
you cannot cut corners you got to take
it
the best gotta find out if you're if
you're a light sleeper if you're a hot
sleeper a cold sleeper do you sleep on
your side to sleep on your tummy sleep
on your back helix mattresses sleep
matters sleep matters sleep matters man
that's the thing about helix you're
right when it says when when beds are
for more than just sleeping the bottom
line is
they got
they've got all kinds of things they've
got optimal pressure they've got these
coils they've got all this technology
that actually does give you the best
sleep possible but forget it here's the
best thing about them sleep on it for a
hundred nights risk-free if you don't
like it they'll come and get the
mattress from your house they pick it up
yes they will give you a full refund if
they give it up meanwhile it's
american-made it's got a 10 or 15-year
warranty depending on the model
and again it's 100 nights risk free
awarded number one mattress picked up
by gq and wired magazine i don't know
why i'm doing this my hands
but it is a great mattress and they're
offering 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for t5k listeners go to
helix
sleep dot com slash fighter let's heal
it helix
helix sleep.com
fighter with helix better sleep starts
now listen you you like sports you like
money yeah and you want to get into the
ufc this is your chance we've got
draftkings now then the ufc 278 it's got
usman and and edwards it's that's going
to be a hell of a fight yeah what do you
got i know who would go to drive i guess
i know put all your money on brian
cowan's pick of
no i don't i i i think usman i don't bet
against a champion but edwards has a
good chance of doing something here mma
fans ufc 278 has an action-packed fight
card capped off by the anticipated usman
versus edwards rematch it's finally here
throw down and grab your own epic
victory with draftkings sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
the ufc this saturday new customers can
bet just five dollars and get two
hundred dollars in free bets instantly
win or lose and if that's not enough
action you can also get a 10
risk free same game parlay just combine
multiple bets like which fighter will
come out on top and how long the fight
will last and a bunch of other different
ways you can do that so download the
draftking sports book app now use promo
code fighter uh bet five dollars on ufc
278 and get two hundred dollars in free
bets instantly that's code fighter this
saturday at draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of ufc
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for detail new york
i like i think some cultures like boston
new york
you tell they're good storytellers
because you don't get away with it
because you tell a boring story when
you're growing up in new york
philadelphia [ __ ] jersey
boston you get stopped
yeah you start telling a story that's
boring guys go hey bro this is [ __ ]
is there a point yeah that you get
killed before you even get out of the
gates actually this is a fun subject
when's the last time you were really
afraid
like when you go oh i'm scared right now
like what's the last time you were
scared that's a really good question i
was thinking about it i know i just try
to remember and like any time a girl
tells me a story about how she's scared
i'm like man it must be terrible being a
chick because girls like a girl they
girls just their whole lives they're
scared yeah every day it must be
terrible to be a woman i'll go there go
oh my god you won't believe what
happened i go what i was in the elevator
and there was a guy in there and i'm
like yeah yeah
i was like that's it i was like that's
the [ __ ] story you're scared
because a man was near you in society
steve burns doesn't joke like that he's
like his girl called me you'll never
guess what almost happened nothing
because it was almost right
yeah they'll be scared just because like
guys walking down the street and they're
walking down the street they're like
that's that's a terrifying story for a
woman
a year ago my buddy we were in the south
of france
thank you and he said let's go it was
night time and he goes it was raining
and and the waves were huge yeah
i'm not a surfer
i don't know the ocean that well right i
don't like the ocean at night
and the currents and beer ritz are crazy
it's where like a lot of big surfers go
so he goes you want to go out and i go
[ __ ] it yeah nice and i just went off at
night yeah and i went out in the water
and it was well it was dusk so it was
like you know but the waves were so
[ __ ] big and i couldn't i couldn't
get out i couldn't get past the wave
well i was getting passed away but then
i was really out there yeah and now
these waves and i'm having to really
focus on catching the wave at the right
time right with my board and a guy had
to come and [ __ ] save me the [ __ ]
server
get my line and toe me yeah out to even
further where i wasn't getting you bit
off more than you could chew me i did
but you can't surf it but it was raining
the waves were big and i was like i'm
just gonna do this because it scares the
[ __ ] out oh that's the last time you're
scared i think so i think something this
guy was trying to seduce you too yeah he
did that too yeah he's not i'm super
scared we're in the south of france
together you want to go uh into the
ocean while it rains you're like are you
trying to [ __ ] me yeah yeah yep on the
on the board yeah all right i guess
cause like that is something i'd say to
a lady like you know who cares it's just
raining his brain's fun and that girl's
like he is fun
this board is hard on my dick why am i
not wearing pants wait why are you over
there on your own board come over to my
board
huh why are you using i'm trying to
think last time i was afraid you guys
chin was the last time you're afraid you
can fight and stuff
and mark you're like a strong guy i
don't imagine you being afraid of
anything but you don't know lions or
something no i'm i'm you've got to be
sorry another thing is you don't put
yourself in positions to be scared
of like being adults like i used to fall
all the time doing skating now i just
don't do that you know what i mean
as far as injuries go but i will think
of the last time i was scared it's tough
to think of that's how cool it is to be
a dude i will say this anytime i see
cops i get a little scared you do like
driving you're like oh my you know it
has an effect or you know when you're
getting arrested um it's just i'm pretty
brazen about cops
i'm
i treat them like they're my gang you
should yeah that's probably they're my
game they are yeah and if a gang member
starts acting up i go wow take it easy
or i call my gang yeah
so my gang's going to beat your gang
yeah oh yeah my guy's got helicopters
yeah we have german shepherds my gang is
going to win let's keep escalating this
yeah and government money it's going to
be awesome yeah they're going to get
away with all budget that's my gang
i'm afraid of um the future
oh yeah yeah
i'm always afraid of the future because
i don't know where i fit in it
do you ever think about where you fit in
this new [ __ ] future of ours yeah
what do you mean where it's kind of a
deep question i don't know i mean i
think that if i was telling eric griffin
this last night like if i uh
if i'd have known the world would be
like it is right now current day i would
have went to school for like editing
i didn't think i'd ever spend my life
spending so much time going uh the time
code's this and how do i how do i make
it sound better here
can you put words on it and uh oh do you
tip it down i've been having the same
thoughts yeah i'm paying all these
editor guys i'm having to do all this i
don't know how to do it and also it's
like so much of my life is just trying
to figure out how to put what i'm good
at on the internet
right you wouldn't want to do it though
yeah concentrate on what you do and just
have other people do it everything takes
up so much time well but also okay
that's good that makes me feel a lot
better but also if i was an editor and
knew how to edit man i would never run
out of work
yeah because everybody needs content
right you're my dumb buddy's wife
sorry he's great his dumb wife
even she needs content she's like oh i
got to put up content i was like you're
just a lady like you know she's like
yeah but i sing while i cook and then i
eat the food on camera and i have like a
hundred followers there's a lot even she
needs to know how to edit like you know
like it's crazy yeah
that's just me she is very high yeah i
mean she can get followers in yeah yeah
just eating food yes people love
watching people eat that's weird huh i
love it how do you do tell people buy
followers
i don't know i see that a lot i think
it's i used one time i bought followers
and it was like 10 bucks or something
they gave me like a thousand followers
really and uh but then
they weren't real accounts so like after
a while like you lose 10 the next day
yeah then like uh like two days later
you lose 10. you just they eventually go
away and then also i've read that
although a long time ago enough is still
true that instagram knows when you've
bought followers yeah so then they bury
your stuff correct so you get punishment
it's bad in general i don't want fake
following because i wanted to lie yeah
but engagement answer because i've been
to your page before
you're like proportional to the amount
of followers you have you get a lot of
likes a lot of comments people engage
with your profile and that's really the
number one thing is like do people look
if you have a million followers and
you're getting a hundred likes and three
comments that are all like fire emoji
nice picture yeah it looks weird also
girls who have three million followers
because they show their ass
that's a that's that's a weird
engagement it is a weird monster it's
almost like fake it's weird it is well i
don't the the app said by real followers
i didn't know that they were all fake
followers so i don't want fake followers
i don't know i don't want the number to
be buy real followers either i don't
want to buy anything yeah you don't want
to buy followers yeah i i only did it
once a long time ago and it was possible
all of that [ __ ] is a slippery slope
it's the same thing as like you know if
you get sponsors that you don't believe
in you know why i did it why i bought
those followers i had an audition for a
netflix show with carol burnett and i
knocked out of the park even during the
like what would be considered like a
chemistry read even though it's like
reality um it was like we went and did
basically like a segment with carol
burnett i'm in the same room with carol
burnett doing this awesome show it's
basically like me and her are like uh
with these little kids and the kids say
the darndest things and carol burnett
like kind of goes back and forth and
whatever and uh it was down to me josh
wolf and russell peters and the reason
russell peters got it is because these
old people at the network no offense
looked at his social medias and was like
oh look how many followers he has but
here's the thing i know those old bozos
didn't they didn't go well let's do some
homework and figure out if they're real
followers they just saw the number and
said whoa
russell's followers are real i know that
but i'm saying but if i
had the same amount of followers
they wouldn't have known if it was fake
or real yeah so that's what made me do
it and i was like i'm gonna scam the
system here i'm just going to try to get
his mouth full of the world yeah but you
got to buy a lot more than a thousand
yeah and there's also
that used to probably be a lot more
impressive now people will look at
engagement no all these little you know
little tricks the app knows the hack so
you can't do anything i don't think
carol burnett's people know who has real
followers or not i was i was in you know
obviously in tahiti this past week and
my buddy goes why are you not posting
anything oh my god i was like [ __ ] dude
i don't want to but okay it sounds like
you run
no i was there with my my whole family i
was literally there with my extended
family no you run your own social medias
yeah i mean when i'm when i'm there i do
i lie about that all the time a woman
would be like i dm'd you and you never
saw it like after shows and nice out and
i'm like oh i don't run my own d i don't
remember my social medias
which is a lie here's what i'm doing
look here you go
one time he you facetimed me twice and
both times you were in like a cool place
i know like a beautiful city you're like
in greece or something yeah
i love it man you're like you got a good
life well i mean
my face is super oblong look at that no
it's not you look good buddy look at
this guy i'm modeling i'm bought
modeling look this was a joke
this was a joke was it though i get it
in my eyes
you just
yeah my hair also look at comedy clubs
hitting on you wise guys i'm doing it
i'm doing wise guys this tomorrow
one show tomorrow actually
do you guys have a lot of followers in
pittsburgh um
oh maybe
yeah well hopefully you do because i
have a show in pittsburgh this weekend
at enclave in pittsburgh and we've sold
about four tickets really
four tickets why don't you do the improv
in pittsburgh uh because uh i think i
did like their last weekend before they
like remodeled or whatever i just
haven't been back you're at the enclave
theater enclave in pittsburgh man we
need to clean you guys yeah august 20th
please come which is what i don't want
them to go hey man it's saturday we sold
four tickets here's eight bucks yeah do
people know how good you are at comedy
yeah uh i don't know i should know
because anytime very nice about to see
jeff die with other people
people who came to your show and said
they were [ __ ] dying well thanks man
yeah that's all i'm good at stand up
yeah you're really good yeah oh and
[ __ ]
stand up [ __ ] what are you doing just
making people laugh and [ __ ] yeah
bill hicks used to always say man [ __ ]
the audience jeff dye says [ __ ] the
audience
love it who's your favorite who are your
favorite comics ever yeah um
i love daniel tosh i think he's so
underrated i think he's a genius i do
too uh
a lot of the usual suspects so like
chappelle and bill burke i went up to
daniel tosh with the first time i saw
him at the laugh factory we were like
contemporaries you know it's not like
sure
i was doing my thing and i came up and i
said i think you're the best comic
working right now and he goes that's so
not true i go no this was about 10.
10 years ago yeah he won't receive
compliments but but i i didn't know him
and i was like no i'm i i'm i know the
difference and i'm telling you i think
you're that good i said standing in bill
burr about you know seven years after
that but
but yeah i i think he's incredible uh
the first time i ever met danatosh i
went because now now we know each other
but i had just moved to l.a i've never
seen him i've never been to the same
state as him and so when i saw him i
went right up to him and i go hey man
you're a genius and he goes no i'm not
and he walked right by me and left
that is crazy yeah he's he's he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's brilliant about i mean
there was a famous comic who i i won't
mention and i was talking to daniel
because daniel had seen he liked uh
i think uh kingdom i was doing kingdom
and he was a fan of the show and we were
just talking about it i don't know him
well but we're having a great
conversation and um i've always had
great interaction with him
and uh a famous comic came up and said
we should have lunch and he goes oh no i
could never do that i did that i i had a
three minute conversation with you about
uh five years ago and that was way too
long
that's what he said today i think shaub
has a good story about uh i might botch
it here but schab's got a story about
how like rogan said to daniel uh he goes
hey man you should do uh you should come
to the podcast and tosh goes why
and joe's like well you know we have a
good time and you know it's fun and he's
like no thanks and just like walked away
like just perfect daniel tosh fashion
daniel does not give a [ __ ] it's really
interesting he's because as a guy i'm
always a little bit way more polite
because i guys fight yeah do you know
what i mean i'm always like i'm always
like
if i'm gonna be that way i have to
either i don't like the guy and i i'm
gonna gotta be ready to throw down i
guess that's my old school way of
thinking yeah yeah like i'll never talk
behind somebody's back on a podcast like
you'll never hear me say bad things
about somebody unless i'm gonna say it
to their face sure sure for me
gossip is not i it's not my generation
it's not what men do yeah if i'm gonna
say [ __ ] about you i'm gonna say it to
your face because i don't like you and i
have to be willing to back it up i guess
that's i'm not saying that that's right
i'm saying that's how i was raised so
for me to say something like
say there's a guy out there i don't like
and i say bad [ __ ] about him
that feels like i'm hiding behind a mic
sure right yeah and so then i feel like
i'm i'm being cowardly i guess he can't
defend himself i'm guilty of it all the
time yeah i'm just i'm just saying i'm
not good at the roasting thing like try
to be funny or i'll say a thing because
that's really what i think and then
later someone's like did you say that
and i go yeah that's my bad man
yeah like i did i said like a terrible
thing about owen benjamin on uh
on jimmy dore's podcast but i only did
it because they were going in on them
yeah yeah so i was like all right i'll
join in the living room do you know
joining the little reindeer games here
so i just started saying all this
terrible stuff but but just jokes they
were all like punchlines
uh like i was like oh i heard owen
benjen selling a new uh his merch now
he's selling his his uh his memoir it's
called mein kampf you know which is a
stupid joke and then um did he i guess
he goes off on lots of different well
but i felt so bad leaving knowing that i
was gonna get poster then he's to find
out and then i'd be like yeah man i'm an
idiot so i just tried to nip it in the
butt i just texted him i said listen man
these guys were all saying all this
terrible [ __ ] and then i joined in the
reindeer games and i shouldn't have i'm
sorry owen's response was so great he's
like oh it's cool man yeah you're my
homie man you can say whatever you want
about me yeah it's if you don't know me
i'll [ __ ] kill you
like he's like you could make fun of my
wife i wouldn't care because because i
know you yeah he's like but if you even
just said like the slightest thing wrong
about me like my experience
my experience with owen i i don't know
what got him banned and stuff but my
experience with owen was that he was the
sweetest
nicest [ __ ] guy he would buy
everybody drinks i don't know i guess i
where is he what happened we get along
we get a lot of fun but where where is
he he moved uh he had some kids and
moved to uh where his wife is from yeah
i don't know i think he also got really
heavy into this is just my uh
interpretation of owen is that he got
into like uh real intellectual stuff
like like he started listening to
intellectuals and getting into these
more kind of deeper subjects he got and
he took that so serious that he started
a podcast and started tackling these
kind of like bigger things which aren't
as light and fluffy as stand-up or
playing piano or telling jokes and i
think because of that that's just my own
assessment because of that i think
that's kind of affected his career a bit
okay if that makes sense seems like he
got into politics he got into like a lot
of that stuff like i remember one time
he's on twitter he just kept saying the
n word and he was trying to make the
point of like why do we give this word
so much power and all this he was trying
to make a point but really all everyone
saw was a guy saying the n-word on
twitter a bunch overall that's a tough
thing to say
it's also really not his message to tell
you know yeah i've just always he's i
swear to god i've only had
i've only had good me too encounters
with him he's he's good to me he is the
sweetest he's always for me for me
he was always the sweetest human being
i'd ever like oh yes i like him a lot oh
i think that
that's that's my assessment is that i
think he just he got into stuff that
really isn't what comedy is you're also
going to publicly beef that's my crowder
i remember like because i was following
this stuff online
in like youtube politics that um just
he it seemed like he was on a spiral
yeah he also would have pointed me at
that way i don't know what's going on
and i hope that i didn't word that weird
word like i want to get mad about that
but i think
if you come from the world of i'm an
actor and comedian and i play piano and
i make people smile and laugh and then
you do this hard shift to like let's
really deep dive on
trans rights and you know or like you
know stuff like that questioning these
kind of mainstream now you know
but like he was probably saying some
stuff that would seem more normal now
yeah you know but it's like at the
beginning of cove or whatever it's like
yeah these are the crazy people now
they're like actually then i had a point
it's also like it's also a terrible city
to be republican in correct and he's
conservatively public yeah
and he's very much a conservative uh in
a lot of ways and uh
and a lot of subjects so like you know
that also probably drove them bonkers
yeah i don't know this is not a very
tolerant city yeah oh for sure i mean
this sounds tough but this town is
really hypocritical because this town
hollywood with a lot of very rich people
they're all conservative but they just
don't say right they have to hide yeah
but they're all [ __ ] conservative as
[ __ ] i promise you well i'm not saying
the trump supporters i'm saying they're
conservative yeah someone said a really
smart thing i don't remember who it was
but they were like the problem with this
town is that uh and this is just la in
general but maybe everywhere in america
is that like the people on the right
think the people on the left are wrong
and the people on the left think people
on the right are evil
like that's okay one side's just gone
these people are a bunch of dumb dumbs
man they don't know what they're talking
about yes and then everyone over there
hold them over there are racist and
terrible you're like no yeah that's just
the other opinion yes but there is that
version of that remember when it was
like save the children they're eating
babies with adrenal chrome there is that
version to the left too but they're
different things that they paint each
other with yeah the left to the right is
you're all racist yeah knee jerk which
is terrible but the right has a version
of that where it's like oh yeah
you're all you know you all eat children
yeah
well that's what my sister was
in tahiti my sister was talking to
somebody she knew from l.a and they had
a friend there
who said uh yeah well who's the racist
friend and and my sister said what she
goes who's his racist friend or whatever
and she goes what do you mean racist and
she goes well he the trump supporter
right and he was being serious and and
she was like uh hey [ __ ] oh yeah
some people are trump supporters
and this is coming from somebody who's
not but some people are trump supporters
because
they the other side hasn't worked for
them even a little bit right so they're
but but what you know trump has
alternatives that they find way more
favorable doesn't mean they're racist it
just means that they want anything but
this woke [ __ ] left-wing agenda
which has its own and you see it more
like it was confusing at first when
trump rose to pop i'm like what are
these people seeing him
now it makes like a hundred percent more
sense
everything that we've done it's like
yeah man well you know
well i think it all comes down to just
likeability yeah you can do anything you
want if you're just likable and you
can't do anything if you're unlikable
yeah and so like donald trump no matter
like you could you could find something
he did that was reasonable or good and
people be like what how dare you defend
him because he's just so unlikely he's
also likable i don't think he's very
like there's another side there's
another side that thinks he's [ __ ]
hilarious yeah like i like watching him
in debates because the guy cracks me up
yeah i just i i i think he's a con man i
i actually don't think i think he's so
he's he's into trump yeah anything else
other than trump that's my that's always
been my problem personally
but he is [ __ ] he's also a liberal i
don't know why everyone doesn't realize
yeah he was a democrat he was a
supporter of the product he voted
democrat his entire life he gave to
hillary clinton's campaign
and everyone goes uh republicans but
he's also unapologetic he's just like
[ __ ] you i changed my mind yeah people
like uh but he he does know the economy
like a lot of people will say that
there's a lot about him i've heard a lot
of business people say they don't like
him personally but his economic policies
make more sense
than the democrats economic policies i
don't like him at all i don't know
anything about him
we talk about chad all the time
it seems weird to us because
like a globalist whatever neo-liberal
economic
stance is like oh that's crazy talk but
then it's thinking like actually yes
yeah there is something to it at first
it just sounds it won't shut up about
china right
now right he was right he's thinking
like i don't like trump then everyone
goes yeah jeff's on our side and i go
don't get carried away i think you guys
are a bunch of idiots too
don't think i'm republican just because
i realize liberals are stupidly annoying
don't paint me in either camp yeah and
it's like but they think oh he must be
on our side because he says bad things
about trump's like no i just i don't
like unlikable people yeah i think trump
is a very unlikable guy although i did
have a dream recently that trump held my
hand in a car
and in the dream i was like so excited
like i can't believe this is happening i
can't wait to tell this story also i've
got a pretty powerful friend here you
know like in the dream i was really like
i can't believe we're holding have you
ever had a gay dream no i have i've had
oh this is gross i've had dreams that
i've was having sex with my sister and i
wake up
mortified
like like it i like i'm like i was
traumatized i've had that dream probably
like three or four times in my entire
life and every time i'm like what so in
my dream in my in my dream yeah i've had
i've been having i talked about this a
long time on the podcast i was having
sex with somebody and i was like
with a dude and i i remember in the
dream
being like this is the worst [ __ ] i like
it was i'm just not i'm very straight so
it was just it was so to me it was so
bad but i was i was like well here we go
again and i was like i'm like here we go
again and i i think i was getting nailed
i really do and i was like of course
yeah that's the scary part right nails
and i'd be like not doing the nailing
i'd be like here we go again and i have
to get on my tummy i remember it yeah
it's [ __ ] dude well that's probably the
more emotional role it's like if you're
a straight guy and you're like taking it
that'd be the thing that like the stuff
of a dreamworker sure is so much
emotionally
actually that might be the first time
some people go you're homophobic and
then uh people always go no i'm not
afraid of homosexuals i just i they'll
say like i just don't agree with it or
whatever their opinion is i think i'm
not afraid but maybe we are afraid
i'm just kind of of the sex part we're
going oh god that'd be scary huh yeah
yeah are you kidding me yeah like also
when i look at you you're a very good
looking guy i would never
be able to make out with you no not in a
million weird you're a dude i can't do
it i'm not in a million years i've
thought about this a bunch it's just not
but i've had i've done plays or i've
done like there are tv shows where
you're supposed to make out with the guy
and i'm like yeah i i just it's nothing
there auditioning for that i'm not you
know why i've thought about this a
million times is because i always
say in my act that i wish i was gay you
know because i prefer the company of
dudes
like i'd much rather hang out with guys
all my friends we have such a good time
everything's good but then i have to
like depart from all my guy friends to
go have sex
yeah
but if i could just be into it that part
it would be so much easier my life would
be just so much easier but i was in jail
and said that he goes if i had access to
women i would never have wanted to leave
yeah free food with all my boys i get to
hang out play dice [ __ ] lift play
cards [ __ ] around
i mean i was trying to explain that to
this girl uh i don't want to outer on
the podcast by name um
but she was like she thought she was gay
she had a girlfriend for three years the
girlfriend broke up with her and then
the girlfriend was like
uh she was so or she was so broken up
about like the breakup so sad about it
that she went to a wedding started
flirting with this guy and then her and
the guy had sex and she's like oh my god
i forgot what it's like to have sex with
a guy dude i am straight again like i i
was wrong i am not i might be bisexual
or something but i'm definitely not a
lesbian like it was the greatest thing i
missed it like this was the best oh man
it was just something about it and i go
yeah you're just talking about exactly
what i you prefer the company of women
yes because they're nice to you and they
listen and they're you know you guys
have a ton in common and then but then
you but you want to have sex with dudes
yeah yeah that's that's the life i'm
living it's funny you say that because i
prefer men but i don't want anything to
do with them sexually i have a friend
who has a lot of gay women friends yeah
she's friends a lot of gay women she
actually works with a lot of them some
of them are her asians and stuff and to
a woman she told me that like all of
them
end up like almost all of them they're
obviously are very gay women who are
just in women but a lot of them who are
in these relationships
[ __ ] end up missing dick and go back
to dudes i wonder if there's some sort
of like closeted lesbians well so like
they're out as lesbians but they're
closetedly sneaking around and getting
dick well yeah because i think a lot of
women must be a thing a lot of people
are into they could be married but
they're also attracted to women right
but don't get it twisted they like men
that's what i'm saying that like in
their mind they're like i could never
let anyone know that i'm sneaking off
and having dick you know because i hate
men and i don't want anything that
exists yeah and they're like but i also
need it you know it's like a drug or
something no my friend my friend's would
that be cold he's a good looking guy and
he that's that's happened to him a lot
of times like at
a restaurant in fact
these two
yeah these two hot
lesbians one of them was really hot and
they were they've been they were gay
straight up gay and she was in a
relationship with this other girl for a
long time but she was [ __ ] just
crossbit hot yeah just
and uh
she started getting drunk and she my
buddy went to the bathroom she don't see
a lot of hot lesbians i know that's a
mean take you do
i showed up from seattle they always
look like me yeah well these girls
this girl was like i know they exist
muscular but also hot as [ __ ] and she
met him at she he was at the bathroom
and he kind of like came out and she
just kind of met him there and [ __ ]
them really in the bathroom that's
pretty cool and her girlfriend was at
the table how does this happen how does
this work
well oh yeah she's one of the best kara
d levine is she bisexual or she i think
she's bisexual i think so too
a lot of times i don't buy it a lot of
times i got i got serious
hippo eyes
uh well here's the thing also some
people might listen to that go that
guy's a dick he said there's no hot
there's not a lot of high lesbians
here's the thing they don't care that i
said that
yeah lesbians don't need me to be you
know they don't give a [ __ ] they go oh
so some straight guy thinks i'm not hot
they're also going for a more masculine
i know she was gay yeah and here's
here's actually this isn't proven my
point the third
look the third was kate mckinnon from
snl that's the that's the third hottest
lesbian in the world no no give me a
break
but female sexuality is more fluid
what does fluid mean uh it can change
unlike guys
seemingly it's a scientific consensus
that you can go back and forth or that
startup
is that i don't know good night she's
from this is not uh who i consider to be
they're not saying the hottest and
they're they're saying like uh just
[ __ ]
famous oh my bad
they're ranking it in family i love
james she's from that because black goes
from a zombie show
has wanda sykes told a joke in the last
20 years i don't know
every time i see her on someone like oh
this is going to be funny wanda sykes
and then she gets on and just [ __ ]
and moans really yeah
she's like you know what it's like to be
a black woman in america
like you're a millionaire wanda who's
this we think you're hilarious
a mandela amanda looks like a younger i
i got i got uh i got skeptical skeptical
hippo eyes on this one too what does
hippo eyes mean like how my test looks i
don't quite buy it oh
you love animals don't you but
i don't know dude big animal guys she's
really good looking hippo eyes and she's
gay is your skepticism because she's
good looking
yeah
she's got that straight lip i mean let
me just see something
oh what's that one there's a neck just
who claims she's uh trans and i i find
it hard to believe
trans she says she's trans and her
wikipedia but i don't i don't believe
her i know that's a weird thing to
question no why are you questioning
elliot page right now who else i don't
know who that is
no there's a girl she's a she's a
comedic actress she's very funny but in
her wikipedia she's she was on i think
you should leave
with tim robinson but i don't know what
her name is she's very very famous and
very funny i think you should leave or
should leave
uh with tim robinson and uh she's one
she's the main female actress on season
one and two
so she'll be in the cast i guess if you
do that i'll just do that
not that girl cast
there it is yep patty has maddie
harrison she says she's trans
but uh she doesn't but she's a girl
she was a guy does she claim she's i
don't know what that means i think she
said she's a biological male who's now a
female but she also is the type of
person to
say all sorts of stuff you know yeah
because she's she's funny like that
she's like a troll she's honoring all
right go back up go back
up well i guess it would be personal
life and children in vietnamese mother
mary father father
mother
janitor
okay but here's the personal life part a
transgender woman
shortly after dropping out of ohio you
what a weird thing huh delete seeking
dinosaurs
she's hilarious i mean like literally
one of the funniest people like she she
kills it on the on the show everything
i've seen her on she's hilarious and
then also she um i'm just vouching for
this has nothing to do with her being
trans but then the uh she did a thing
where she changed her twitter picture to
nabisco and then changed her twitter
name to nabisco and since she's verified
as patty harrison it had like a little
check mark so people thought it was like
nabisco and then she started tweeting
all these things that like nabisco would
tweet like hey you know we're in this
many grocery stores and all this
different stuff then she goes also we're
excited to announce this uh musician
sia is going to be taking over our
twitter tomorrow and the next day she
pretended she was sia tweeting from the
dabisco website and then sia would go
hey i'm so excited there are only two
genders and all these people started
getting super pissed off at nabisco
and uh she sounds great yeah she's
hilarious i love people like this uh
yeah and so she got banned from twitter
is never okay thank you for holding us
accountable we are better than this we
start to learn and grow as a brand and
you make that possible i'm going to
swing from the chandelier from i'm going
to swing with the challenge for the
chandelier and it says sia trans women
are men all caps like it's just such a
funny
way to
troll the world and also get nabisco in
trouble got sia in trouble like she did
all this great stuff she's a hilarious
hilarious uh woman
hello i'm sia the singer we do not want
your business you're bisexual that is
some next level [ __ ] yeah if you are
bisexual
oh man she's great
[ __ ] yeah i gotta watch i think you
should leave she makes me laugh so hard
yeah but uh also tim robinson is
brilliant yeah yeah i like was like a
fanboy we happened to be in detroit at
the same time when i was shooting a
movie and he was shooting uh like either
he was shooting a new show he's english
right he's detroit he's from detroit
born and raised yeah [ __ ] he's brilliant
um but anyways i found him i was like
i'm finding this guy when my buddy's
like i'm working on the show of his i
was like perfect set me up i want to
hang out with him so i got to hang out
with him at a tigers game for like
three minutes
but it's worth it you know you got to
find your heroes who's your team
baseball mariners seattle mariners
you're not a baseball guy huh i was just
at the uh
dodger game is great with padres i
wanted shot to come to the orioles game
i throw the first pitch for the orioles
still ceremonial first pitches i throw
one out for the baltimore orioles that
he was in baltimore like mistakes
oh yeah these are uh
is there a music here
yeah okay i can't do that but we can
watch and these are all the you played
all the ones i've thrown so far that one
i launched into the sweets why did you
throw it on the 200 level i thought it'd
be funny and then the the
gm of the mariners kevin martinez goes
that was our worst first pitch we've
ever had and i was like i think you mean
best first pitch because i was on
twitter and he goes save the shtick for
bill murray and i was like all right so
bill murray he was like mad about it so
after that i threw only just good first
pitches after that no more gags
love the mascot you love it i love it oh
yeah it's funny you look like a baseball
first time i ever uh i always like to
throw to the mascots it's my favorite
there's the baltimore one coming up
great how many pitches have you thrown
something i think uh 13 or how do you do
it you just call them up no uh it's
actually quite a process i basically
hunt them down the way i hunt down tim
robinson i go who's got a contact and
then i use that contact to meet whoever
and finally figure out who the person is
who who organizes it all and then you
gotta make yourself sound way more
successful than you are you know just
shot a movie
stuff like that yeah i [ __ ] out all my
credits yep i go oh you won't believe
what i'm doing now yeah i'm the host of
the fighter and the kid and just show
him this one episode
the fighter and the king and then they
see how many followers the fighter the
kid has they go this guy is a really big
deal on the way back today from the
airport the guy the
customs guy just goes brian gallon dude
i took a week off because i knew you
were plugging into edie i was like
that's very nice to you sir that's nice
i know we didn't have a podcast so
that's good
how often do you get recognized
i don't know it depends yeah but i mean
i never get recognized in l.a but
everywhere else people people come up to
me and say hi it's like the only town
it's always like when i like i think
this is the time where if they recognize
you they just don't say nothing yeah
well but like in bora bora i got
like you don't know until then hey i'm a
fan after that do you like it when
people come up yeah me too i love it
yeah i'm never i love being wrecked they
go i don't want to bother them i like
bother my kids i'm lonely yeah my kids
get excited because the you know
the customs guy with his gun is like oh
[ __ ] you know yeah that's fun for me but
like guys would be like oh man you're in
uh st louis
uh let me know if you want to get a beer
i reply right away i go yeah uh they go
really i go yeah come pick me up i don't
know anybody in st louis my girl said
somebody hit me up i don't mind at all
my girl sent me a thing i forgot to
answer back sent me a dm and he was in
bora bora he's like let me buy you a
drink but he was at a different hotel
everything's on the water all right take
a boat over there oh i make them come
get me and everything and they can't
believe it's happening they act like i'm
some superstars and they go this is
crazy i go yeah it's fine let's just get
some let's be i need someone to talk to
yeah [ __ ] yeah i'm the same way sitting
in a tampa i don't think i'm better than
you yeah yeah i really don't well that's
why i like all those comics that work
with me and stuff like i don't know shop
i guess he stays the airbnb and yeah he
orders food and he's kind of you know
he's a family guy yeah but shop's not
trying to go to bars and meet girls
whereas like i'm always trying to do i
make the comics that come with me hang
out with me the whole time they come
back they're like jeff is he wants to do
stuff all that my buddy zacho stayed
with me um from chicago very funny
comedian look up zack oh great guy but
he stayed at my um place for like three
or four days and he'd be like i gotta
rest man like he was like pleading with
me he's like i gotta go home he's like
no way we're going to the chimney sweep
he's like dude it's midnight i've been
we hung out all day at the pool i'm i'm
stoned out of my mind i was like no
we're going to the chimney sweep and
then at midnight yeah that's zack oh big
handsome he's six six so i'm like that
big tall cool guy but anyways uh so he
goes to bed in the guest room or
whatever and uh
i just call my buddy jeff z and i go all
right we're going to the chimney sweep
he's like hello dude it's like my social
motor is insane how do you uh so so do
you get stoned a lot i never get stoned
i don't i don't smoke weed but you drink
a drink yeah he goes you can drink all
day yeah no problem no broom
and then you can get him to do stand up
yeah that's good and drink you don't
drink
no i can't drink during the day i'm
[ __ ] oh yeah it was funny and i i can
drink less and less but i just thought
it's funny the zacho like this cool
young guy he's younger than me and he's
going please please just let me go to
sleep
just pleading with me like this is come
on buddy come on buddy it's been a whole
day
that is kind of doing too much stand-up
lifestyles yeah when you're younger well
i just like talking to people i've
learned everything i like has to do with
talking if there's talking involved i'm
in
my buddy we're at the dog beach and he
goes he goes we should rent atvs because
we saw some tourists go by on atvs and i
remember in my mind i didn't say it out
loud i go no way dude we couldn't talk
i thought like who would i talk to if i
was on that atv with the helmet on it so
you're not in it like things like
fishing or fishing we can talk yeah
but like darts you say let's go throw
some darts and say yeah we can that's a
fun game we can talk but like
snowboarding no dude i'm on the mountain
by myself with headphones reading
reading what are we doing i don't like
it like like you don't like solitary
kind of like being alone
you'll talk to people next to you in a
plane my ex-girlfriend was like i'm
flying to chicago i wish you were on my
flight because i too was going to
chicago i was supposed to and uh i
almost cancelled my flight just so i
could fly on the same flight so i'd have
someone to talk to so you like talking
to somebody on the plane yeah i don't
talk to you well if i well i don't talk
to strangers on the plane no not
generally because i'm stuck with them
yeah yeah yeah that's a little different
that is that's sorry that seems
inconsistent but you you're happy tell
it's cool when you're on a plane and
you're running like three comedians that
you know oh that's the best i just there
was a run there where i saw ian bagg
every sunday how's he doing he's good
yeah he's the best one of my favorite
people comedy road dog i've never seen
yeah he's a real dog well before the
pandemic he had like a um
residency in vegas so i'd see him there
all the time and then we'd always be on
the same flight on sunday coming home so
i was like getting a lot of ian bag time
just because on accident he's a good guy
american airlines always had better seat
than me he did he'd like that to be
known
[ __ ] he sat in front of me yeah the
rich get richer
piece of [ __ ] he's a good guy man i love
him what who's in first place baseball
wise uh the dodgers are killing it
yankees are killing it um
yeah mariners are doing good but we
picked a bad year to get hot because
every other team is way hot
fernando tati's junior just got popped
for steroids that's some baseball news
really yeah he's gonna suspended the
whole year how many people are doing
steroids do you think nobody does
steroids no more
that's why it's such a big deal that he
got popped yeah
because their bodies don't look as
muscular well it's just like how are you
gonna get caught in 2022 doing steroids
like it was different when it was you
know well yeah what are you doing them
now for
can you say i keep your hats always
going to be ahead
what do you mean this chemistry and
underground you know labs are always
going to be one step ahead uh as far as
the techniques to evasion is always
going to be one step ahead of detection
so
much harder to do but i think if you
have the money you have the resources
you have a willingness to do it there's
a compound out there right now that's
undetectable
you know people are always getting
caught retroactively like dimitri
klockov in the olympic lifting you know
ten years later it's like you're juicing
i like to i like uh i always love
hearing the athletes try to wiggle out
of it that's always my favorite they get
popped it goes public and then the
athlete's always like oh uh i
accidentally mixed up my sports drink
uh oh the other day i was at the park
and i fell into some steroids like they
always have a terrible stress daniel
zarian said he was on i don't know what
it was on he was saying people have no
[ __ ] idea how many actors and
athletes how everybody is juicing i
might what do you think you and i might
be the only guys not doing it well the
cops juice every cop jews i want them on
steroids i want them bigger and stronger
faster i heard a ton of the fire
department is on steroids also it's okay
to be on steroids if you're not in pro
baseball or pro like that's the only
reason it's bad is because they've made
a rule about it in a sport yeah it's not
against a lot for mark harley to do
steroids look at him
it sure isn't yeah
what do you got let's see what we got
here all right corinna vance it's karina
fans do you want to start off with
something that's kind of like
yeah crazy it's gonna feel bad watching
it not at all i don't feel bad watching
anything
i watch 911 on loop at my house so we
can't play this on air but you watched
what you get this was crazy yeah so yeah
dude i love this clip so it was the
teenager i haven't seen this it's a
smoke shop this is a 22 year old owner
and these two guys come in with this
this guy's done this before why are they
trying to steal vaping watch out i try
to steal the money yeah i love that jeff
hasn't seen this i haven't seen it i
don't like this that's a terrible uh
mask jacob he said his name how stupid
is this [ __ ] oh
that's a knife
oh my god boy he lived though right i
hope i didn't get the actual that's a
big blade
he goes yeah and then he just kind of
drops him here and walks calmly old
school
no guns or nothing my kid's done it
before
that stupid teenager who just got his
[ __ ] life caught up so wait so can we
figure out what happened to that kid
yeah um what i was going to say i loved
myself
he was still alive
um
i hope he's still from what i read they
didn't get the uh details from those two
kids like it's nowhere but if mark could
find it i hope he lived because that kid
was just i know because he's just a
stupid kid that tried to
i don't think
he didn't have a weapon but jumping on
his 16 year old kid did he live no
okay but also let's take some
responsibility you wore a mask
into a store so stupid knowing like
we're going to work let's just go in
there and jack this place i mean there's
that kid was vietnamese i think you
don't [ __ ] around with vietnamese or
asian or korean whatever the [ __ ] he was
you he they thought uh this guy's asian
he's a [ __ ] good luck you don't know
what they thought that but you're tired
about it
that was both ends of the spectrum on
crazy don't [ __ ] with vietnamese they'll
[ __ ] you up you don't [ __ ] with the
vietnamese or koreans or the japanese or
whatever he was but i was already going
wait a minute and then you go uh
he probably thought he's asian he's a
[ __ ] they did crazy
i guarantee that like like people they
profile they go ah guy looks like he's
[ __ ] a nerd or something yeah right
good luck wait the guy that stabbed him
was a vietnamese yeah really did he
yeah he looks like he's mixed but you
can tell because of the footage but yeah
it's kind of what also how bad of a
robber are you if you go hey jacob come
back here
both teenagers
they're just
and they were just dumb even the way
that they were like they were so nervous
you could tell because he was like why
are you guys wearing masks like that and
they're like oh yeah it's like what
that's wild wait so you guys feel bad
for the kid that got stabbed yeah i do
because i think he was just a stupid i
don't think he's gonna get stabbed no he
got in there without a weapon he was
like let's rob the store it's one of
those dumb things you do when you're 16
years old and then you get stabbed like
that and it can [ __ ] you up for the yeah
and then and then your mother's like oh
my god you know it's yeah i don't mind
guys who have guns who come in and try
to kill somebody and they get [ __ ]
shot in the face i got no problem with
that
it's a 16 year old kid who's not
thinking his brain isn't fully developed
and he's like i'm going to do something
crazy and then he gets stabbed 15 times
yeah that was a big blade too did you
see the size of that blade man that was
no joke and he just stabbed him all over
the joint dude everywhere the legs yeah
the legs are the back like he was he hit
him here on the first one i was going oh
that's a bad spot to get that size of a
blade in awesome all right so i don't
know i don't know whose side i'm on it
all seemed pretty no you're just all
super excited the shopkeeper is in his
right because that guy came over
and you don't know what's gonna happen
so you're allowed to defend yourself
which he did i was hoping jacob would
get stabbed though not the other kid he
stabbed him right [ __ ] there too one
little step over here he would have been
dead but he got him there looks like he
got his trap
dead there uh
somebody you know was arguing with me
actually i think it was jay actually on
the road jay shop was saying no he's
going to be prosecuted
just sort of guessing looking at the
scenario and going you can't you can
defend yourself but you can't do this
right there's still oh yeah the nuances
now in a state like nevada i assume
it's not going to be
uh
you know super uptight about a shop
opera shop owner stabbing a criminal but
it's an interesting little legal it's
like define defending yourself
first of all the guy jumped over the
counter when you jump over the counter
with a mask you you your lawyer is going
to be like dude he didn't know what the
[ __ ] to expect people get shot all the
time that's my perspective all he did
was go because he said you guys please
leave and when he said that the guy
jumped over and he went i'm not [ __ ]
waiting for this guy to draw me boom
boom boom boom the jury that i don't
even think a d.a takes that case i think
versus what if he's running away and you
go and stab him sure that's well he did
turn his back but even then like it
happened so quickly you're just like get
away from me here's a question so like
let's say those jump over the thing they
steal like cartridges or whatever the
heck they're trying to steal their money
and then they leave
he goes calls the cops the cops come
they give him the footage to the cops
what happens this kids probably just get
away with it right it's not like the
cops go okay here's a voucher for all
the stolen goods right there's not like
an insurance company's going to give you
right like is everyone that's a really
annoying thing because people think it's
okay to do bad things to businesses
because they go well they're going to
insurance it's like well at this age i
know a lot of business owners now and
it's not really that easy
it's not just like oh yeah insurance
covers everything and go ahead and put
spray paint all over because who cares
it's just a business well that was the
thing with blm yeah when they were
tearing up businesses had nothing to do
with blm they were just destroying
entire businesses right all up and down
melrose and those are people [ __ ] that
people own businesses and they get work
there
right it's very tough to do that yeah
but what i'm going to say is so maybe
that's another reason this guy's going
this is my [ __ ] shop and these
teenagers are about to jack me and i'm
supposed to just put my hands up people
die that way all the time when you're a
store owner like that you're very aware
that people get shot
and stabbed and killed all the time that
way we might also be naive like me
thinking like well it's just a knife
like i'm not going to go to if i had a
gun and i shoot a teenager i might get
you know but it's just a knife
who knew he'd do so good with that knife
yeah
he was really good at it
that's a small knife actually it's about
it that was
like a six inch knife it's like under
let's take a look i think it looks
gigantic bro i don't like watching it i
mean i mean just to see the knife
look at that look how long it is right
it's i think it's there yeah that's a
big blade and i don't know if you could
hear this jeff but the guy goes i'm dead
i'm dead yeah he collapses look at how
he says he didn't die but this dude
knows what the [ __ ] he's doing this is
just not relenting that's the spot right
there
i was going to say earlier you got to
treat this like if you're the kid we
should teach kids to go this thing
you're about to do what's the worst case
scenario right you're envisioning
robbing this book these videos are good
right what's the worst possible have you
just considered the option that this guy
could kill you right people need to
think about that when they road rage
when they do any of these things like
man if you unleash the the dragon in
certain people like this he's thinking
oh man we'll just
well worst case we'll get a rest we'll
get a slap on the wrist for stealing if
we get caught for robbing this place
nope no you're you get a wheelchair my
guy like you you you your life is
significantly different because you
wanted to i i i don't know what happened
these guys they say they say nothing i
think no as far as i saw it like the
i guess maybe because they're young they
don't want to give updates on this oh
yeah that's the problem to the hospital
you know
do we know that they're young
17 issues oh he said that yeah there was
a few guys arrested and one guy was
going to be arrested at the hospital i
saw a kid uh just on facebook the other
day
they hit him and his buddies like for
fun you should throw [ __ ] off the bridge
just for fun i used to do that all the
time but we did like water balloons and
stuff these guys were throwing couches
and they were throwing like rocks they
threw a muffler they threw like all
these different stuff and a rock went
through the windshield and killed a guy
like immediately because the car was
driving so fast and the rock was so big
that it just hit the guy's head
killed him immediately and those kids
one of the kids going to jail second
degree murder for 30 years oh yeah and
they're just punk kids yeah who were
throwing away so they're [ __ ] also
i'm not i'm not supporting them but i'm
not saying in the same way
i think about the consequences yeah
actually yeah they're sitting there
going oh we killed a guy yeah and then
human consequences where it's like hey
it doesn't that just like things could
happen to you think about it yeah a man
died
a guy who's like he's about to be you
know he's about to i think he just was
engaged he had like a regular life he
also didn't do anything wrong he's just
riding in a passenger seat of his
friend's car like yeah just now every
time you go under a bridge i think oh
man maybe did your parents ever say
the thing to you my dad always used to
say this don't ever punch settle don't
ever sucker punch somebody because you
can kill somebody with one hit you would
reference like you know cardinal i don't
know if it's yeah carter
but you can kill somebody with one hit
because if you knock them out and they
fall in concrete my dad my dad hit a
dude and he his head it was at a bus
stop with my mother he punched the dude
yeah and the dude and my dad
when he was in his twenties was six four
two thirty five two forty just giant
irish guy
boom hits him in the in the face and he
said the guy fell back and hit his head
so hard in the payment that probably
happened my dad he combed the obituaries
that he was going to jail right he he
looked at the obesity series for
about two weeks after that yeah [ __ ]
and dead guy
i might have done that one
that's scary stuff man well you know and
i've really learned something here today
you know yeah that i don't know what i
how i feel about i don't know what
happened shop owners
defending their businesses wow because
you guys were really uh
you guys had some opinions about it the
major response to when you look at the
comments everybody's like yeah [ __ ] that
kid
it's sort of a visceral response
especially with everything that's going
on now where you go people are being
robbed and getting away with it like you
like this this guy's a you know i get it
i'm not i'm not criticizing the guy who
stabbed him
i'm a fan of anybody that protects
themselves i'm just saying
i think in that case that was some
stupid [ __ ] kid with his whole life
ahead of him and he just tried to do
something daring and brazen or if he was
like tough like you guys like ufc stuff
if he had just knocked him out right
just like punch from the [ __ ] side of
the head and like put his knee on like
you we'd be rooting for him wouldn't we
yeah that guy could he easily had a
knife himself but the knife yeah makes
it a real big uh like a place for keeps
because
thinking about worst case scenarios too
the the stronger did say that he thought
that the guy could have a gun sure but
he thought also like probably didn't but
he he has to imagine that he did like a
cop yeah the store owner shouldn't say
[ __ ] without a lawyer right now i'm yeah
so he was talking to the news stations
i don't know
he's doing a whole victory lap going you
guys see me yeah it's just so violent
it's just ah it's so crazy to watch and
hey and hey this was crazy
like going on this crazy spiral downward
spiral right for a while
alcohol drugs so she
she did die but then i'll show you some
of the footage of her driving through
before you crash into this footage of
this yeah holy moly this is prior to her
teeth well that's her dodging like
literally almost hit this guy in an
alleyway
you see how fast she's going yeah real
quick
and there's one where she's speeding
and a ring camera catches it
she's what you'll see right here this is
a ring camera yep and this is down a
regular street
that's like flying down the street and
then i think you could hear it
there it goes yeah into the house that's
wild
and that's the house
that she drove through yep and it was
just some random person's house yeah her
car caught fire
and then she was in the car for like a
long time right mm-hmm these poor people
in that house i know i think everyone in
the house is fine no they're okay i know
just lost some stuff yeah well the whole
awesome pretty much
what is the deal what's this lady saying
man was she just did she just so they
thought
tons of drugs i heard there was some
sort of a breakup and then she was on
cocaine
and she just wasn't in a good place so
who knows but she's been down going down
this downward spiral for a while she
tried to kill herself right yeah that's
what it looks like
it looks like that
why would you do it that way
i don't know usually women are very like
uh particular about their suicides right
yeah according to malcolm gladwell ah
yeah i read that
well you're just talking about like
you're not blowing your brains out well
like i'm trying to think what book it
was it was a
i don't remember what the but which book
it was he's got somebody it's his book
called
self-harm
yes book called when jeff wants to talk
about ladies killing themselves yeah
well anyways he's basically the idea is
like this the san francisco the golden
gate bridge right all these people are
jumping off of it and so then one guy
was like hey what we should do is like
put a net there that will catch them or
put some sort of fence that they can't
jump off the thing and it kept getting
voted no because everyone's like well
they'll just find a different way to
kill themselves we're not saving anybody
we're just they'll just find a different
way but it turns out that if you take
away someone's way to kill themselves
that makes them go well that's the way i
was going to do it i just won't do it
now because they're very particular yeah
it's like especially women are very
romantic about how they kill themselves
they don't want to leave a mess usually
so like they usually won't blow their
brands out where men don't care they'll
just blow their brains out women will
think like well who's going to find my
body wow who's going to see this
you know so like it's very like intimate
about how they will kill themselves so
that's why women tend to not kill
themselves that's heartbreaking this is
pretty reckless i don't know if i would
call that a suicide might be called she
was on all kinds of drugs and and
my buddy my buddy was a cop and and he
would investigate cold cases um he would
he was it would international in
international waters weird
and there was a woman same thing she she
went on a cruise yeah and she wrote all
these poems and she [ __ ]
weighted herself down
in the middle of the night she waited
till she was in the deepest part of the
ocean she'd done all the research yeah
and she weighed herself down with a
backpack and and and she tied it up and
she tied she had a chain down her body
so she couldn't get it off and she just
jumped into the water man at the deepest
part of the ocean and
left a note and just disappeared
and that that's interesting man because
you just wanted to like kind of just
disappear what do you think makes me
[ __ ] sad yeah it sucks it makes me
sad dude also like going down same with
same with the bridge because they you
know the documentary that uh people jump
off the bridge and they'd have footage
of it the people who survived were like
the moment i jumped off i regretted it
yeah you know what's gonna [ __ ] you guys
up is when you have kids
because when you have kids everything
becomes unbearably sad when you think so
so i think about ann hayes i think about
people jumping off the bridge when you
have kids
you know that it sounds [ __ ] up but
like you know that's somebody's child
yeah and you know that's somebody's
mother you know that and man dude it's
like when you it's it's unfathomable in
a weird way
i'm just a big [ __ ] i'm a way bigger
[ __ ] now that i have children yeah but
also i'm just at an age where i cry easy
yeah i see things like i think maybe you
just you might be blaming your kids for
just becoming a good guy
you're just a nice guy yeah i am the
things you thought were cool when you
were 19 or when you were 16 or 12 isn't
what you think is cool now now you value
humans and life i was always that way i
was always um somebody who
cared about people's feelings way too
much
and that [ __ ] me up a lot like i i i
would always bring like rogan would
always say especially
women and so he goes you bring broken
and crazy into your life all the time
dude and it's gonna bite you in the ass
yeah and it did and and
i was broken and crazy
you know looking back on it you have to
take responsibility for how broken and
crazy you were because you would you
would bring that in because it was a way
of staying broken and crazy maybe i
don't know yeah but but but you know i
would always try to fix people yeah well
see i'm a little desensitized to
things that aren't in my circle of life
right so it's like i always say it's
like you can't care about everything
right so like for example like all these
people die every day yeah why aren't you
sad about that why aren't you sad that
10 people just died in vietnam right now
like no no you didn't know them right so
i kind of do the same thing with these
and people go jeff you're being
insensitive i go i don't know ann heyche
i'm sorry that it didn't affect me
because i don't know she's as much of a
person i don't know as those 10 people
that i just referenced just died that's
true i just don't know
i'm not happy about it but also i'm able
to
make light of it and not really make it
ruin my day because i don't know them if
i found out you even had like i mean the
first time i ever met you i was like hey
man i think it's like i i love you and
like so now it affects me yeah it's like
but if it's outside my sphere yeah we're
gonna care about everything evolve for
that yeah well
i think
like she's had
her life i think her dad
molested her and then both her parents
died of aids
how about that is that true yeah look
that [ __ ] up she had a [ __ ] google i
was at a
school party on sunday and i had to uh
yeah i was at a pool party on sunday and
i had to actually google who ann haisch
was because everyone there was like
actors and stuff like did you guys hear
about anne heish yeah i had to google
ann hayche i never heard of her
look at that
sexual assault at the hands of her
father man biphobia anti-gay mom who
denied oh yeah that's a dude
multiple levels of mess you up as a kid
going on
and those are the type of people that
that commit suicide right
everyone is severe childhood trauma oh
sure her father sexually assaulted her
when she was a child and family
experienced homelessness her father died
of aids how did you know it's 1983. i
thought this was a thing you made up or
something look at that and her brother
was killed in a car crash she's been
through some [ __ ] dude yeah come on
think about that
her uh father died of aids
one month exactly after i was born
i was born february 4th 1983. and she
was old
i don't know
well i'm uh 39 so she would have been 20
or so she's like she was like she'd been
12 or 13
i'm guessing
why do i look so [ __ ] young you guys
yeah you look good buddy i'm all right
it must be tough just aging as a lady in
hollywood too the toughest yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] dude are you kidding me to be uh to
be her might not have been as exciting
as it was uh a while back yeah that's
yeah i would say that's exactly another
so that's the father does that to you
you're done
100
right yeah because your whole identity
is my identity and existence is rejected
by my father or my parent all her
childhood until she was 12. okay good
luck good luck with that it says she was
molested until until she was 12. so when
she was she went through some [ __ ]
little kid brother died in a car crash
dad dies of aids which is probably a
blessing but also and then now in modern
times in 2022 she dies in a house fire
in a car crash too weird house fire
what else
what a [ __ ] mess we'll add that to it
there was a
dude they had to pull the plug on her
she was like essentially brand new
branded in the hospital they they i
think they donated their organs all
right they were looking at if they're
good
that's an interesting thing [ __ ]
uplifting show everybody uh yeah people
like this you know they donate organs
that are from well here's a weird thing
about donut organ donors like i remember
being like i'm like yeah you can have i
don't care do anything with my body i'm
dead dude i mean i don't even you know i
don't need to be in a cemetery any of
that stuff it's such a waste but
i didn't realize that they're not going
to take my
heart and go give it to some kid that
just got blasted by a school bus who
needs a heart
uh they basically donate them to like
science
like college kids do like work on it
yeah they don't want that yeah that's
what i'm saying like you you're not
being as noble as a donor organ donor as
you might think you would be i thought i
was that's what i was doing hold on my
driver's license says
yeah like this
that's annoying here's a quick one so
we're doing a fight companion this
saturday at 19 am and then she was the
co-main event she's a very pretty girl
yeah she used to fight for the ufc uh so
she pulled out but there's no real
reason why she pulled out she just
wrote this message interesting i did not
pull from my fight i was pulled and
pissed heartbroken
i worked my she spelled worked wrong i
know she's she's pissed off right now
my effort ass off to be pulled she also
screenshotted her notes
and then she also you know you can just
tweet
all right
let me show her your instagram real
quick
what's this with uh what's tj talking
all right it just pops up sometimes but
this is her instagram she has her own
little thing called jesus christ
paigefanzant.com which is her version of
only fans she's hot for a fighter yeah
but um there's a girl oh there you go
what is that pose that's her boyfriend
who's also a fighter husband i don't
know but what are these photos
it's to promote her
website for people to go there
let me just tell you
listeners
if i get married or have a girlfriend
we're not posting [ __ ] like that
whatever
what if you made like
i think she made a few hundred thousand
a month she's already making money i
think she makes all the money yes she's
probably like a multi-millionaire she
didn't have to post that to make money
she's making more money though she made
money off that post right there
you wouldn't do that no what about the
reverse what if you were bent over like
that
this is insane that this is even a
normal thing
you're coming off like a real christian
conservative right now why like you're
like this is just disgusting
what about it is wrong to you
what it's just uh it's unnecessary it's
distasteful so it brings people to that
website and then they have to subscribe
so this is kind of like enticing them
you know tempting them but is it not
like social media is unnecessary oh yeah
you guys unnecessary is not the right
word i find it it's straight it strikes
the critics
it's very gratuitous it's pretty
hardcore considering it's instagram
yeah like it makes you uncomfortable
well i guess let me think let me chew on
it a little more here's the thing
if if like it's a porn star i go yeah of
course that's what they're doing but
this is a girl we're supposed to respect
as a fighter and a man we're supposed to
respect as a fighter he's like here's a
photo of me and my wife doggy stuff it
just seems like they're not i think some
things should be for you guys
not for us
but that isn't that's a taste thing but
here's what i thought i'd be a
generation here's what i thought was
if it was my wife or if it was my girl i
made it about me yeah i i think when you
do that you are
um
putting yourself in a
certain category let's put it that way
what do you think when you see that
um i get hard
well i just think myself like how
embarrassing that you posted that on the
internet with you in the sense that like
i'm part of my brain goes there's
nothing wrong with that mark at all
people can do whatever they want people
can whatever they want
you would never do that yeah actually
because again i do like i have this
feeling like like when people want to do
like kissing like photos i'm like right
kissing the bed here's why i don't like
it yeah i just never thought about it so
okay like i'll be loud with my guys in
the bar and we'll have a good time we're
hooting and hauling we're saying stuff
we're joking around it's great we're
having fun
right there's a difference between that
in a bar then those dumb pedal cart
things you'll see where everyone's
drinking and they're peddling and
they're going down you're like why did
you need to be observed
just go have fun in the ball i think we
are talking about i don't i don't love
those two i'm sure they're great people
and i hope they are great sex and i hope
they're awesome fighters i don't need to
see them butt humping on instagram maybe
maybe why do they need to make me view
that maybe what you're objecting to is
that it's it's a little bit vulgar
i'm suggesting and what i mean by that
is it makes sense
seem [ __ ] fraudulent yeah they need
me to view it
they're they're monetizing their they're
monetizing yeah i guess yeah they're uh
i guess that's what i'm judging they're
monetizing their there's a pornographic
aspect it makes me not really respect
the the thing you know very hot though
i'll tell you they are
good-looking people i thought about this
i like women being sexy in pictures and
stuff like that and i'll post shirtless
pics but i always try to have like a
funny caption or something it's hard for
me to take myself seriously in it like
i'm being sexy right now context yeah
and then put that online let's do a
photo shoot it's where i'm choking you
and putting my finger in your mouth it's
like why don't you just
i couldn't make a joke i couldn't help
but make a joke out of it you know yeah
and again then again we are talking
about it and just working and they're
making a lot of money right well i'm
sure they're going to make a ton of
money and i have god bless them it's
just weird to me that i had to view it
i've actually spent some time with both
of them and they're [ __ ] great so
it'd be like being like a cow check out
this picture of my [ __ ] and then you go
hey man i don't want to see that and i
go oh god you're coming off real
christian
conservative [ __ ] are normal dude yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i show cal and mike [ __ ] and all of
a sudden he gets all conservative on me
are you getting all tight yeah don't be
weird i just posted my [ __ ] on the
internet just because everybody and
everybody's judging me
all right here's some of mark's i know
what you're saying
i'm gonna go with the instagram yeah i'm
sure the comments are gonna light me up
for them
nice
the cat can dance dog
i can watch this all day
surprisingly captivating there you go so
this is what tick tock should be
cat's doing cue the person's doing the
dance that she's she's working right
dancing imagine the time that you would
spend into this right because the
chorography is actually really yeah and
that cat's hands are very bendy
i didn't know that did they break the
cats
in their cats supple bro
the word you looking for suck yeah do
these cats do yogurts [ __ ] yeah they
supple
wait who posted that mark did
uh no well i it was just something i saw
that's great bud
story of the week
everybody wants to talk about anne haiti
in that house fire but you got a cat i'm
into this cat
cat dancing who's this guy
uh mark andre feely yes so he was doing
stand up and i actually thought it was
pretty good he's a ufc fighter ufc
fighter okay guys don't laugh i'll feel
right at home because i've been in a
relationship for six years the same uh
girl and she don't laugh at anything i
say anymore
we're six years in so she's like four
and a half years past thinking anything
that i [ __ ] say is funny
um
like she used to say [ __ ] like when we
first started dating she'd be like she's
like oh my god i love your sense of
humor you're so
so funny and now she says [ __ ] like uh
everything's a big [ __ ] joke to you
isn't it
yeah that's good
now they're doing a ufc comedy jam huh
they are is brennan headlining that
he's got to be the most famous ufc he
hasn't commented for sure
i don't think he'd won
that's his first time hates being
associated with like the ufc oh he
doesn't like that could people stop on
the street and go like
oh man like
they'll bring up fighting or do you ever
want to get back and he's irritated by
that questions because he's still now
i've encouraged him i think you should
bring it back more and talk about your
fighting more i think he's like
at the end of a phase where he's like i
don't want to do have anything to do
with it's just like fighting in my
comedy that makes sense i would do jokes
about it it's because i think you could
circle back yeah dude if you're such a
giant guy
and also maybe if maybe someone because
you know not everyone that sees
brennan's shop knows everything about
brendan shub so they might be thinking
look at the size of this [ __ ] guy
right you know they might think that
yeah or if he references it yeah it
might help
the the perspective you have now even
like whatever 10 years out of the league
it's it's different
yeah every premise could start when when
i was fighting back in that day because
i mean imagine this must be some great
material and like only he could do yeah
i can't say that i've never been able to
say when i was fighting
when they used to lock the cage and i
was there with another monster who's
this guest okay she her pronouns and i'm
a licensed professional counselor and
sex therapist in erie pennsylvania and
today i want to talk about minor
attracted persons what
probably the most vilified population of
folks in our culture and
most folks are making incorrect
assumptions about them without actually
knowing much about them
and those assumptions create harm
or an already marginalized population
you may have noticed that i'm using the
term minor attracted persons sometimes
abbreviated to maps
instead of the more commonly used term
pedophile right and i'm doing this
because the term pedophile has moved
from being a diagnostic label to being a
judgmental hurtful insult that we hurl
at people in order to harm like the way
we call you a bozo
you [ __ ] dope person first language
that recognizes that any label we might
apply to a person is only part of who
they are and doesn't represent
everything that they are
we are all
people first with many different facets
or parts of ourselves and this includes
folks who are attracted to minors
i wonder if ann heyche would agree with
this lady
right
i bet she wouldn't yeah i bet she
wouldn't uh but you know whenever
somebody like this gets up here and does
this it's it's just
it shows you what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like what morons on whatever size she's
on whatever side you want to talk about
if it's this crazy far left it's just as
crazy as the the far right or worse but
i mean
and apparently not doing yourself any
favors licensed counselor and sex
therapist use licenses yeah yeah they
are marginalized and vilified because
i'd like to punch him i'd like to shoot
him in the face god i'm so tired of that
kind of stuff and i know that people
will if you're a pedophile about turn
yourself in
or like or voluntarily castrate yourself
you know or kill yourself that's how
how's that sound
people are
oh this guy how okay before you start it
who is why does this guy pop up on
everything i have because he he gained
the system yeah he did some kind of a
like if you subscribe to him they have
to post about him or something like that
so he was just getting he has this
hustler's university it was insane
right but there's small different
channels it's not one channel right
there well also stop calling bad things
clever
i don't like when you go yeah but we're
taught yeah i know well we're talking
about it because it's wrong
but isn't that great aren't they smart
you're like no they're not smart they're
evil but he's actually entertaining oh
yeah but what i was going to say is like
my algorithm knows jeff man knows me it
all my whole every algorithm is just
showing me home runs
dogs you know beautiful women boobs like
that like it knows what i'm into
but then this guy will pop up and then
also
millie brown whoever this [ __ ] chick
is from stranger things why is her [ __ ]
popping up
i have to keep going on i i don't like
don't send me stuff like this it's
always millie brown
home runs baseball and this guy
all right so go ahead
no don't worry andrew tate
i think that stands for wet ass [ __ ] is
that what it stands for yeah so by cardi
b and someone are you talking to a
stallion or some [ __ ]
[Music]
complaining about the lyrics so i listen
to the song i listen to the lyrics
everyone saying they're degenerate and
they're disgusting sure that's what
women want
uap
is a sex manual for men
she's telling you exactly how to [ __ ] so
that women don't leave you and don't
cheat on you so if you listen to these
lyrics and you're like oh i can't
believe she said what oh my god and
you're offended by it yeah within your
little [ __ ] not really
it's on you i don't want my kids to hear
you dork yeah it's on the radio you [ __ ]
yeah obviously
duh
duh that's what they want so they've
always wanted
people are complaining no no i don't
want brian callan's kids going on the
floor on tick-tock rapping that's what i
don't want by the way i don't want
brandon's shops and kids
singing in the back seat to his lovely
wife and him going
that's what we don't like done
i'm grown up i can hear wet ass [ __ ] i
don't want society running around
bouncing their [ __ ] on the kitchen
floor
at eight years old doing instagram reels
yeah
obviousness unoriginal
obviousness yeah also i also don't like
to think of women like that because we
were told to respect women now it's gone
don't objectify us all objectify us yeah
yeah don't objectify me i'll objectify
you as a weapon yeah i learned how
wholesome jeff is this episode yeah i'm
a good guy well if a guy still likes
women right because i spoke that way
about
her and did a song like that he'd be
cancelled so yeah she's talking about
well it's like we don't uh like that's
you can't say be respectful to us but
then also hey why can't i talk about
buckets of fluid coming out of my [ __ ]
you go well that seems like a crass
weight of time yeah crash is the right
word yeah it's like i'm not mad about me
i can handle it
it's about that it's about being on the
radio i think it's interesting most of
us
have this sort of like
we do that we all go i don't know it
doesn't sit well with me yeah
it's like
it's i don't really want a society
that's
embraces
anything yeah anything goes i get
accused of being uh like
sexist and misogynistic just for in the
tone of the way i like to joke about
things correct but yet i've never met a
female comic who isn't toxically
masculine
huh every female comic i've ever
listened to
is just like yeah well
you know i told him he better use me and
win ass but it's always like this kind
of
bro talk yeah they're allowed
so like i'm not allowed to be toxically
masculine in even the slightest yeah but
when women do it it's like isn't that
different
she'll say anything
oh she's wild yeah you're like no she's
she's doing what we get in trouble for
yeah and i hate that inconsistency yeah
it seems stupid
that is sexist that guy i like that guy
generally but that was a terrible take
on his part do you guys agree or
disagree with me am i wrong um i think
he's just being i don't take what he
says seriously because i think he's just
he's being a fighter
he's being a firebrand he's being silly
and funny the the
nugget of the statement though is women
want this
if you take it for that it's going hey
basically women want you to be sexually
aggressive in the bedroom
that was my takeaway yeah i think he's
just being he's just a guy who he's got
a good sense of humor i think he's just
being silly and he's like an outlandish
i love that i love that he talks about
having if you have your friends just put
out a bunch of bubbly water glasses just
pour a bunch of glass of water and and
and the first guy goes
bubbles yeah never speaks that guy
i hope that i hope that he sees me i
hope that guy sees this clip i watched
you do one of your little instagram
videos buddy and i liked it i said i'll
see more about this guy i like it and
then i clicked on the next one and you
basically ripped off a jordan peterson
quote uh like two or three in a row and
i go all right i'm done with this guy
how do you know jordan peterson didn't
rip off a andrew tate quote oh i know he
didn't i got a feeling that the
brilliantly sophisticated clinical
psychologist isn't uh isn't doesn't even
know who that guy is the guy that wants
to fight the paul twins yeah for
whatever it is
guys smoking cigars going hey white
house [ __ ] for bro i think that's a
fight that could happen yes i hope so
yes no ken he first called him out back
when jake paul called us conor mcgregor
[ __ ] world champion yeah well then
that maybe it won't happen because of
that yeah jacob's we all we're all
hoping for it now jake and and logan
both sound good i get them mixed up but
i like locomotion
new molecule discovered that strongly
stimulates hair growth
that guy looks like there's a lot of
hair though yeah so i feel like he's got
a great hairline so many scientific
problems are like well just give it 10
years whatever we are on the verge of
something big i think
and uh all the time see i'll get little
grayers stuff like off the internet like
oh this is a
thing you could put on your head that
binds to the androgen receptor in your
scalp it's not you can't buy it at
walmart but i can pay bitcoin for it and
get a powder and mix it with you know so
there's all these things that are like
they have this powder that's being sent
to me from russia it was just approved
by the you know
we are trending in this direction of
having way more that's the only part of
getting older that i'm not crazy about
is the uh my i think about my hair a lot
yeah yeah i want this people talk [ __ ]
about my hair on this podcast oh he's
got a comb over or whatever it's not a
comb over i
yeah it's like any any any combing of
your hair is you guys comment there's a
kid a little aggressive you know
they get in there they try to find what
you're insecure about they go uh
oh yeah looks like jeff wants to
we should target jeff's hair
they just want to run their fingers
through it yeah it's okay that's all
here don't worry about it i'm a boy but
a lot of great fighter kid army people
there too so oh man i love it i like you
guys
they're my favorite people
um
with a few trolleys uh wait so what is
it so what does this will help me grow
my hair good i mean there's like what
mark this is like the second or third
newest things that came out this year
about hair like actual advancements and
potentially regrowth regrowth of hair
specifically yeah there's a few
different mechanisms in this one so in
line promising because it activates hair
growth in the human hair follicles
because it's one thing to stop it like
finasteride's basically it's stopping
the falling out anti-androgens on your
scalp stop the falling out but minoxidil
stimulates hair growth by causing more
blood flow to the area and if you can
stimulate like microneedling examples
you're supposed to do that do that to
stimulate the follicle if you can do
that you can grow a lot of hair hey how
do you know about all this you got a
great head of hair you're not the best
well like you i don't want to you know
yeah you don't want to lose take it for
granted they're like wait a second like
yeah you know you got you you both have
good hair realizing anything you
probably gained hair stopping you're
yeah you look good buddy
i'm aware you're going to break that
tiny chair i know it's uh we've got the
biggest guy in here he's sitting on what
appears to be like a little fat makeup
tray or something
he's got he's got he's got jeans and
combat boots with no [ __ ] socks bro
yeah dub dude that's my smell all right
what's next here uh so this is from king
and the scene but let me play this clip
for you real quick
one of your co-stars or even yourself
would you smash if you were a girl bro
huh i already rendered the you'll see
all that [ __ ] i'ma send them over
and y'all let me know y'all looking
pretty good would it take ten beers five
beers any beers maybe you're just that
horny gang gang buzz buzz
sword
so this guy did a face swap on all the
guys so theo von brandon
eric griffin crystalia then nick and me
okay as girls as women right okay and
you and you gotta ask would you smash
yeah if you guys had vaginas this is
good all right okay so check this out
oh my god that's theo that's theo
uh yeah for sure i mean yeah all right
for sure uh-huh yes hey guys this is
brendan yes
uh
i i mean come on dude yeah are you crazy
yeah
here's chris yeah dude
definitely that's that's probably the
best one so far you think so i mean it
might be the hair i think they picked a
big-bodied lady too because that's
[ __ ] jealous it's so funny like i
imagine like white hips yeah that
picture of wide even though it's
crystallized i don't know how's it going
her jaw goes why is she hiding her face
yeah she's doing that trick
i would [ __ ] eric griffin before i
[ __ ] that lady
there's nick
uh no no not terrible and they did me so
wrong i don't know who this person is
oh yes
no jen i gotta pass on that i would pass
on it
[ __ ] i guess she's asian it
that's him just dressed up as a girl no
no facebook my coming out party guys i
am a transgender woman when was this
this was on the set of 50 central in
2017
uh that is a character called markeisha
do you should send that photo
uh to wwe and go i want to be yeah i
want to be in the women's division what
a great idea they would they would
the whole movie plot is immediately
flying
to connecticut and give you like a try
change your voice that's your voice yeah
and you say uh yeah you shave the [ __ ]
and you just go yeah i'm a woman i dare
you to question it yeah
and and what's what's my
breaking bad
yeah and the the whole story line's like
trans woman like she-ra key man she-ra
oh that's awesome
you'd get killed by that crowd they'd be
like he's trans [ __ ] that they'd be like
get that dude because you know how like
restaurants always tries to parody uh
current events and these things well you
know you got leah whatever name swimming
who leah thomas thompson yeah she's a
transformer so everyone started talking
about the trans people and athletes
she's swimming or she's swinging
she swam so fast
she could she swim as fast as a guy
she swims she swims so she's in the top
swim against guys if she was on
testosterone if she was normal back to
where she was when she was a guy she'd
be i think she could give some of those
boys a run for their money yep she'd be
in the top 500. but instead she went
over to the women and took first okay
went over to the women
i mean yeah she she's a woman all right
guys tomorrow salt lake city utah wise
guys i'll see you there i got one show
tomorrow thursday nashville tennessee's
80s august 26 27 friday saturday that's
next weekend man raleigh good night
great september 8
9 10. these are all my favorite places
yeah san jose california september 15 17
spokane september 22-24
do you go real clean when you're in utah
or do you just do your normal stuff i do
my normal stuff i gotta talk to that guy
yeah she stopped booking me oh really
yeah she talked to him yeah
illinois
brendan august 26 for brendan
get your tickets uh he's doing a tough
mudder run that on the 27th you can buy
tickets to a tough mudder run appleton
wisconsin he's uh at um
the what the [ __ ] is it called there's a
club there yeah but it's just
a skyline comedy club uh adam rose
brickhouse something like that anyway
september 8th uh to september 10th
ontario ontario improv september 15th to
the 17th and then jeff here's my dates
pittsburgh this saturday pittsburgh at
enclave theater and then august 25th
27th i'm in saint louis at the helium
comedy club september 9th and 10th i'm
at hyenas in uh fort worth texas and
then i'm going back to hyenas september
23rd and 24th to play the dallas club uh
come get tickets for that also if you
subscribe to my patreon you get free
tickets to all these shows you can just
show up and say i'm a patreon subscriber
and i leave you tickets um my patreon is
cheaper than the tickets will be it's
just ten dollars to subscribe to my
patreon so it works out get free tickets
if you want but pittsburgh this saturday
please come see me
also shout out to my boy tyler huge fan
of this podcast he's gonna be super
excited that uh
tyler barker one of the biggest
fighter and the kid fans out there
all right buddy well thanks for doing
this love you bud let's say you're
always welcome i'm happy to be here i
love it here you're great you're oh yeah
also there's a podcast on uh on this
network that i have called 12 packs with
jeff dye oh really where we crack beers
and crack baseball cards not baseball
any cards it's going to move to the main
network yeah i would love to have you
guys on it i'm doing it in my podcast i
started a new podcast the brian cowan
show yeah it's just me just you talking
yeah how long is it like an hour maybe
less sometimes i'm not doing a lot
whatever you feel then i got conspiracy
social club of course on rockefeller we
keep growing
and best of what's the controversial
social drama
boston episodes very soon on best of
youtube bryant.com
tripley comes up with a conspiracy and i
debunk it oh good and it's just like
[ __ ] that's pretty fun yeah it's
great does sam really believe all those
uh i i think he does
yeah you know what's great is whenever a
conspiracy guy and i'll put sam in this
camp because i love that guy
but uh i will say like
it's like it's always like a really good
argument oh that's pretty interesting
and that thing's pretty interesting and
then you'll go you might make a counter
argument that it makes good sense yeah
and he'll be like it's all about money
dude
like then it's like a vague kind of like
thing well that's not a good argument
yeah it's like it's all mirrors dude you
go what
that's the argument yeah it all comes
down to power man and you go well that's
not a good argument for this well that's
that's my take on a lot of that sam's
the best i love that [ __ ] guy and
he's so funny he's great sam is so
[ __ ] funny yeah he he's you know you
you're a comic and it's it's hard to
make you laugh after a while you've seen
so much that dude kills me he's great i
summoned the comedy store for the first
time like live ever i'm seeing him into
that one show comedy chaos uh yeah yeah
he's great it was i did uh leave it last
week or i think i did it last week and
sam triplet was so sweet yeah he said
because he looks like a crazy guy you
know any behave you think he's crazy if
you met him but if you met him he's like
the nicest guy in the world and uh and
in the green room he just kept being
like hey man i'm sorry uh you know i
know you're here but like i got to put
three more on then he's talking about it
like that doesn't happen every night of
my life yeah
the bookers or the manager they they put
me on whenever they want they'll go two
more than you or oh i need you to go
next or oh hey can you you got to go
last they never are like apologetic like
he was like i feel terrible man
i got to put you uh at this spot i was
like whenever you want it's your show
you can put me you can bump me if you
want like it's it's your show yeah right
i don't know but he's just such a
thoughtful guy
and he's like next time i have you on
man i'll get you like a third you know i
was like okay yeah or whatever i'm happy
doing whatever yeah
nice guy he's the best
all right jeff die love you boys i'll
let you go get get to your um go back to
sleep yeah gotta go back do some pilates
yes your step class you get a scratch
lab watch some porn go to bed do you
watch porn yeah
i don't really watch porn ever well i
got a girl i don't know i'm just not
into it anymore i stopped watching it
you're missing out dude
probably what's your do you have a go-to
milf
really really
yeah it's the best you don't say so you
got a pornhub and just cut a milf milf
all right
okay
okay
chicken i don't like it
[ __ ] bully
porn notorious porn bully just 3 15.
yeah so no sign off oh this is the
piranha kid we're out awesome we love
you guys